I what's up guys my name is Franco
Noriega I am the chef and owner of baby
Brasa and I'm also a model and today I'm
going to be trying really hot food spicy
delicious we'll see how much how can you
handle first I am we got is Cheetos
flamin hot
this looks like it's really spicy does
smelt
spicy really but it's really red inside
let's see the first one doesn't really
seem very free always maybe now it's
definitely a little hot I don't know if
flaming hot but spicy is building up the
first thing I taste is the actual cheeto
as I swallow it it's like the spice
kicks in I can feel it a little bit in
my my guide in my throat is definitely
hot [ __ ] if you end up eating the whole
bag you'll probably be sweating your
eyes off but they also become addictive
in a way who doesn't love cheese right
so 1 to 5 I would wrap cheetah are too
many if you want more spice they're
definitely not your option Cheetos
flamin hot spicy baby Hot Tamales this
is cinnamon hot so it's a different type
of heart I think yeah mmm my god
immediately you feel the cinnamon and
that's delicious
I don't feel any hot yeah it's funny how
these hard things work because the more
you eat them the more it really starts
to develop inside your mouth I feel I'm
salivating a lot because there's a lot
of hot going on funny enough it's a
different type of spice sugar goes great
with heart this is more like a hot in
your mouth very strong at the beginning
but very mild immediately but it fits
pretty quickly but I would have to run
this in a hardened spice level I would
run this in a number one
my god this looks fire so our third
contestant is the hot chicken flavor
ramen this already looks super hot if
you see it I mean there's something
about the color of the spice that is a
little scary already it also it also
smells really strong so we'll see what
they have I mean they look delicious the
flavor oh my god
okay so this is really spicy this is
like really spicy like okay I have to
take my shirt on sorry oh my god Wow
oh I feel it in my throat um I also are
we going to put the mic back on oh my
god this is really surprising I guess
water is not permitted right this is
extremely spicy okay guys you right
right from smelling it is already spicy
if it goes into your throat it goes
inside of your tongue like in the inner
part of your tongue I'm also afraid of
going for one more but hmm made of them
as soon as you walked in like I can feel
it so from 1 to 5 days of eat 7 ok don't
try this at home if you don't like spicy
because this is insane I'm already
sweating I mean I can barely speak my
tongue is already like up swollen I need
some water for sure ok I'm done with a
wither ramen to really fire oh my god
yeah I need some water oh my god I'm
afraid what's gonna happen later with my
body also you know so like this is a
type of spice that goes there so caution
okay caution for sure
okay so Satan okay is it saying look at
this the toe of Satan you're supposed to
stick this in your tongue it's funny how
people love the spice it's like you know
this kind of like pain pleasure
sensation people love to be in this hurt
pain mode we can't bear but you know
they still want more
okay so it's called a toe of Satan I
don't know if you're able to see it but
it looks like a toe I mean there's a
nail right here if it is hysterical
let's see how spicy that's all Satanists
it tastes like candy where is he now on
you oh okay I mean so this is really
spicy also if you get to half the table
say that after having the fire noodles
is almost too much you know like I can
barely handle this do I have to put it
inside again no okay this is not
recommended for sure I mean I sexina
won't try I mean I can barely speak as
you can tell this is the most spies
eating i've tried to-- satan is really
hidden oh my god and now I feel a spice
all over my throat and my mouth and my
lips and a scale from one to ten this is
a 20 okay like no way no no more Oh
Satan the tip this is so spicy oh my god
they've never tried something oh my god
I think it's so hard I know I need to
take everything up [ __ ] that I mean look
at this I'm like sweating
[Music]
this is the most spiciest thing I've
tried in my life on anything and water
doesn't do it I mean for some reason I
just it doesn't do it this is how much
you sweat when you get the top Satan and
for some reason the more I talk the
spicier it gets oh my god and we have
one more okay so it's not looking over
okay let's do it let's do it let's do it
so mm we're gonna try the oven arrow
peppers now so this is something I used
to do in culinary school to try the
hotness of the pepper oh my god my mouth
just for you to know is hurting like you
have no idea at this point there's pain
going inside my throat my mouth and my
body I love spices but this is also like
a spice overdose my lips have swollen up
I feel like Kylie Jenner right now you
know like trying to talk like I mean
it's tough to even articulate what I'm
trying to say but it's do it for the
sake of spice because I know you like
hot and you know what I like it too okay
so here we go I'm like so afraid it's
okay
but doesn't feel hmm so I have to be
honest with you guys I thought this is
gonna be spicier but it's not I actually
like the flavor of the pepper I despise
you but I think after everything I ate
it's definitely not as spicy as I
thought it was gonna be you know I think
it's developing now I still think it's
not that spicy so I think we're good we
pass a challenge our hotness level for
this from 1 to 5 I think vida me like a
4 definitely the most spicy one was a
tough Satan don't try that at home I
promise it's only pain pain pain pain
but if you like to feel hot then go for
it I'm Franco Noriega I save you good
kids I'll see you soon can I have one
more water oh my god oh my god it's like
so hot so hot
[Music]